- I've never seen real Indian news,
but I'm ready for it.
(country introductory music)
- I've never seen an Indian
TV news channel before.
- It looks just like a
normal news broadcast.
- Alright, here we go. I'm just
gonna dive into this thing.
- [Man in the middle] Or are
you saying so, one second.
- Don't be stupid.
- [Man on left] Don't be stupid!
- [Man in the middle] No,
I am not being stupid!
I am not being stupid.
- Don't be stupid.
- Doctor Subramonyan is
killing it right now.
He's bringin' the heat.
- [Man on left] You're an ignorant man.
- Oh! Called him ignorant.
(laughing)
- I'm just gonna refer
to him as Dr. Subaru
because when I see SUB, that's just
the word that I think of.
- This is just like, worse
than a Comedy Central roast.
(thick accent)
(laughing)
- He just called him Dumbo.
- This guy is acting how like,
we all did in 1st grade where like,
someone else is talking and
you don't like their argument,
so you were like yalalalala
and you like talk over them.
- He must have said liar
at least 150 times now.
- It's like they remixed it.
This could be a viral song or something.
- So Dr. Subaru is
regulating one, two, three,
four other people.
- I like the host is now
instigating the fight.
- That's just chaos.
- You could just keep
throwing people in this screen
and Dr. Subaru would just utterly destroy.
- I don't even know what
they're talking about.
- Is this news?
- I'm in love with Dr. Subaru.
I wish that he were my Dad.
(heavy crosstalk)
- This is stressing me out.
- They called each other liars
for four minutes straight now.
- The one dude's just still silent,
just sorta sittin' there.
I don't think he even
knows he's on camera.
- I just figured out that
the guy on the far right
is actually made of wax.
So, he's not a real person.
- He's seen like, other country's news
and knows that this is like a farsight.
He's just like, "Yeah, I wish,
"I wish we had like actual
stories to report on."
- It's over now. It just ends.
They just stopped the
video 'cause it kept going.
- Like, you think there'd
be a producer in the booth
to like cut this guys mic at some point.
Show the squirrel water
skiing. Let's just cut to that.
- They seem pretty similar
to American politics
if American politicians
said how they really felt.
- I don't like it.
- It's much more entertaining
than American new programs.
- I think we need to get
Dr. Subaru over here ASAP.
- I'd totally watch American
news if it was like this.
- This is India. This is India right here.
And it's spirit force.
- Which one got the degree from Harvard?
Was it Swami? Please don't say it's Swami.
Shut the f*** up. Swami got the degree?
Swami's loud a** got
the degree from Harvard?
Oh my God! Swami, why?